[Music]
hi my name is Bhaskar Juve agha i'm a
product marketing manager for big data
on the Google cloud platform team thank
you for joining our webinar on Google
bigquery who will fully manage data
warehouse for large-scale analytics I
would like to start by giving you a
quick overview of what will cover today
first I will go through a quick
introduction on Google cloud platform
then I invited Chad Jennings and Dan
McCleary product managers on bigquery to
join me chat will talk about the
benefits of using bigquery and will show
you an exciting demo then we'll cover
the origins of bigquery you will then
give you a peek under the hood so you
have a better understanding of white
bigquery has such a great price
performance then you will share with you
some of the latest features we've added
to bigquery he will also explain how
bigquery integrates with a larger Google
cloud platform and then we'll pass it
back to chat to talk about our partner
ecosystem so let's get started with
Google cloud platform we're building a
different kind of cloud the status quo
cloud of today shares a lot of
similarities with previous data centers
and color facilities of decades past
team spend a lot of time thinking about
servers memory network connections and
storage and while they're not actually
touching physical gear they still have
to manage monitor and care for
virtualized versions of that same gear
we used to use this kind of cloud inside
Google but we realized our business
couldn't scale fast enough on this route
is the complexity of that model so we
have to reinvent everything about how we
built deployed and run software on our
cloud to be able to manage that
complexity out of the equation today we
use third wave cloud combination of
automated services and scalable data and
this is what we offer through google
cloud platform our customers don't spin
up servers but they're appserv millions
of users each minute they don't shard
databases right failover scripts or
patch software stacks and yet their
software is some of the most resilient
and secure ever created this approach
lets our customers code without thinking
about infrastructure consequently they
do a lot less unproductive in first
to work it's an actual global elastic on
demand set of services and this is how
it translates the big data in a typical
Big Data world you have a lot of these
different things to do the valuable part
is programming but you also have to
provision resources manage reliability
you have to do upgrades at Google we
take care of all of that for you you
just do the programming and the rest of
the time is spent understanding your
data and finding insights now I would
like to turn it over to chat so he can
further explain what bakery is and how
it brings the core values I just
explained to data warehouses hi my name
is Chad Jennings and I'm one of the
product managers for Google bigquery so
what is bigquery bigquery is a fully
managed service enterprise data
warehouse what does that mean for you it
means no touching servers no building
indices know managing upgrades or
managing geo replications when we first
built bigquery for Google's internal use
we underestimated how important these
things really were but after running
inside the company for more than a
decade our users really appreciated this
service architecture bigquery operates
at petabyte scale and fast and we'll
show you these demos in just a second we
also offer the convenience of standard
sequel so you can pour it over your
existing workloads or I guess in another
benefit you don't have to teach your
analysts to new lingo and lastly we're
durable and highly available but what do
we actually mean about high availability
when you buy a data warehouse solution
you generally just buy the green boxes
these are the actual servers that you
rent you still need to worry about
scaling them and provisioning for peak
loads etc when you buy the solution from
google we take care of this entire block
diagram for you our idea of highly
available analytics is load your data
and then press the big red button so one
of big queries big differentiators is
its quarry performance over extremely
large data sets and so to convey this
I'm going to be showing some queries
over a petabyte of data and it's easy to
lose track of how big that number really
is it's a one with 15 zeros or in binary
it's two to the 50th but what does that
really mean well if you took a petabyte
worth of data
put it on a stack of three and a half
inch floppy disks you'd have a stack
three miles high that's 12 times higher
than the Empire State Building if you
thought your 4G connection was pretty
quick if you tried to download a
petabyte worth of data it did take 27
years I really hope those movies are
timeless classics the Library of
Congress has every English language book
ever written as well as significant
audio and video collections even that
only adds up to 10 terabytes worth of
data so you need a hundred copies of the
Library of Congress to add up to a
petabyte and I don't know exactly what
this says about us as a society but the
Twitter corpus is twice as big as the
Library of Congress so you'd need to get
to a petabyte you'd need 50 times every
tweet ever tweeted conversely a petabyte
can actually be pretty small as well 2
micrograms of DNA is a petabyte worth of
data and every day this is amazing a
petabyte worth of videos is uploaded to
YouTube every single day and if you had
a pretty significant but not enormous
server farm 200 servers logging 50
entries second you'd have a petabyte
worth of data in three years so petabyte
while being a pretty vast amount of data
it's the size of data that folks are
using every single day and so to show
you how quickly we can scan through it's
headed by worth of data will cut to a
demo right here so this demo we looked
for a petabyte or bigger data set but we
couldn't find one we couldn't even find
one to buy so we built our own we used
40 virtual machines for two weeks solid
to generate this data set so let's
switch over to the demo so the data set
is a retail data set if we look here the
customers table it's a a terabyte table
with 4.7 million rows the products table
is half a gigabyte with two million rows
and the fact table is the sales
partition table and this one is a big
one at one point 09 petabytes and more
than a trillion rose
there are some tricks you can play with
Colombier datastores we wanted to show
you that we're not doing any of that
we're not taking advantage of column
compression by having the same element
multiple times in fact this table
compresses really poorly because it's
got so many unique floating-point values
and we don't have large padding fields a
section of the table that we're not
actually scanning so I'll just run
through and show you the preview here
you can see that it's actually populated
with unique numbers and a lot of them
are floating points so the first query
that we're going to run is a select star
over the entire table with a filter on
the sales order key and so what this
will do is we'll pick out all the
columns obviously and that's not normal
processing for bigquery generally just
pick the columns that you want but we
wanted to hammer the database with a big
fat query so let me get this thing
started here okay and we'll move on to
another example that's a little bit more
interesting while that first query runs
so the second query here computes the
total sales by day for a particular
customer and note that we do filter by
customer because that means we can't
just use pre computed aggregations so
I'll go ahead and get this one running
not to all right so now we're back with
the results from these queries the first
query took about four minutes to process
one point 09 petabytes on a
pay-as-you-go instance that took no time
to set up that's actually pretty
impressive so the second of these large
queries took about five and a half
minutes to finish and that's a little
bit longer than the first because
obviously we're not just doing select
star we've got the filter by customer
key here as well as doing some
aggregations as this query competes the
total sales by day for a particular
customer but even so five and a half
minutes and four minutes to scan and do
aggregations over a full petabyte table
is pretty quick the previous queries are
quite large but we can use partitioning
to save both time and money so let's run
essentially the same query but over a
period of time so let's say we just want
to find customer sales in a month worth
of data so we set up a partition here to
select January of 2005 I'll go
run the query and so while that's going
what if we wanted then only see how fast
we could do up there we are it finished
less than 10 seconds now let's see if we
wanted to see actually how far we can
push this so how fast can we do a
partition scan on this petabyte sales
data so i'll just select the january
fourth of 2005 and let's see how that
one goes all right there we go finished
in less than five seconds that's five
seconds to query an entire petabyte
table that's pretty darn quick the other
queries that we ran with partitions were
a bit small and you simple scan filter
aggregate queries let me get this one
running it's a bit more ambitious and
then we'll explain what it does this
query computes the seven day average
sales across a range of products defined
by a regular expression we're also going
to join against the products table in
order to look up the product name there
we are it's finished less than 20
seconds in the first two queries we
scanned the full petabyte table and got
results back in just a couple minutes
then using partitions we drastically
reduced the time and cost of the queries
to pull data for specific time periods
the last query is a relatively complex
one using regular expressions partitions
a join and aggregations to return the
seven day average sales of a range of
products taken from that petabyte table
all in less than 20 seconds that's
pretty darn fast we'll head back to the
talk now that was a cool demo after
seeing that I'm sure you're wondering
what makes the query so fast and how
bigquery was developed and now I'm going
to turn it over to them so we can
explain where big where you came from
how it works and the influence it has
had on the Big Data industry
hi I'm Dan McCreary part of the bigquery
team now we've heard a lot about how
bigquery can really change organizations
for the better with its ability to
analyze petabytes of data we've also
heard a lot about what bigquery
practically is but after hearing all of
this it's worth reflecting for a moment
how do we get here where did bigquery
come from and that's what we're going to
look at right now now it's important
when we think about where bigquery came
from to think about Google's long
history of tackling big data problems at
Google we like to publish papers and we
like to tell the world what we've been
building because we think it helps other
organizations build things that are
truly revolutionary this goes all the
way back to our earliest days in 2002
and 2004 we published a pair of papers
about systems called gfs and map
produced these papers actually gave the
initial idea to Doug cutting for the
Apache Hadoop project which has taken
the Big Data world by storm more
recently we've published papers on data
flow and tensorflow systems which
generated a lot of excitement around
streaming data and analytics and machine
learning one of the papers that we
published was called Dremel and this was
about a system that we built inside
Google it's been really important to the
development of the big data ecosystem so
what was the Dremel paper well the drama
paper was based on a system that was
written by an engineer here called Andre
Gubarev now Andre had a problem he was
trying to write MapReduce is over many
many many logs and it took a long time
this is a problem analogous to what many
people using open source big data
problems have dealt with now what Andre
did is he started storing his logs in a
columnar format and then he wrote a
little sequel query engine over it and
it was way faster that was really
interesting and soon he's attracted the
attention of an intern and some other
engineers and there was a snowball
effect and dremel became a big deal and
this paper was a bit of a hallmark for
the big data space as well because this
paper gave rise to both the Apache Park
a storage project and the sequel on
Hadoop solutions like Cloudera Impala
and apache drill now where is Dremel
today well drebbel today is still used
inside Google Dremel is googles mission
critical data warehouse it's been in
production for 10 years it's in every
Google Data Center and for internal
usage we query any order of exabytes of
data a month that's an order of
magnitude bigger than the petabyte we
were talking about earlier what does
that stack up to let stacks up to
quadrillions of rows scanned every month
and eighty percent of Googlers use it
every day some of them don't even know
it and dremel is bigquery when you use
Google Cloud bigquery you're using
Dremel it's the same system we launched
just the public as a beta in 2010 and
made it generally available in 2012 it's
the same engineering team and the same
code base it's exactly the same system
brought to you and in the past five
years we've been busy improving Dremel
we just didn't write it and let it sit
idle you take a look at the graph here
the yellow line shows you the number of
code changes to Dremel over the last
five years and these are the same code
changes that go into bigquery each of
the blue flags represents a major
milestone that we think is important to
customers these are things like dremel X
which we'll talk about in a moment and
some of the other things that we've done
around faster data ingestion and better
support for the sequel language that's
five years of innovation but what have
we done lately well to take a look at
this we first have to take a look at big
queries architecture now importantly
bigquery dis aggregates storage and
compute now this allows us some real
advantages we can summon thousands of
virtual CPUs in an instant to service a
query however this is all dependent on
Google's incredibly fast data center
networking because our networks have a
pet a bit by section it means that even
though that storage is separate from
compute it runs as if it was all in the
same gigantic machine so that pata bite
can be scanned and processed incredibly
quickly now one of the improvements we
made was to the way that Dremel actually
allocates these virtual CPUs to the task
at hand let's take a look at the Dremel
architecture from 2006 to 2015 now in
this case we relied on what we called a
long live serving tree now this looks
very similar to those of you coming from
the database world to a directed acyclic
processing graph or a query plan and
that's exactly what it is now this was
very useful in terms of being able to
simply scan and process lots of data for
common queries however for certain kinds
of queries maybe wasn't ideal so
recently we produce something called
Dremel X and this architecture is much
more dynamic you can think about this as
Dremel optimizer or big queries
optimizer getting much smarter about how
to allocate compute units in an instant
to the queries at hand now what does
this mean for you this means massive
joins get faster most queries got an
order of magnitude faster and everything
just works and revel ax is available as
part of bigquery now users who switch to
the systems didn't even know they
switched they just woke up and queries
got much faster and we continue to make
improvements like this to bigquery every
day now we've talked a little bit about
how bigquery takes advantage of a legacy
of big data advances inside Google but
where does it fit within Google cloud
platforms data architecture or your own
data architecture let's take a look now
if we zoom in one of the things we might
really care about is the fundamentals of
data warehousing or big data systems
where do i load and store data and then
how am I going to analyze and understand
that data now if we look at the load and
store side of the house you can see
three things that really form the heart
of that part of our reference
architecture you have google cloud
dataflow which is used for etl streaming
aggregation and a number of other things
you have google cloud storage which is
designed for incredibly low cost planet
scale storage and then we have systems
like Google big table which is designed
for IOT data time series and other
things that tend to be calm family in
nature now on the analysis side we've
got big query which obviously we've been
talking quite a lot about but for those
of you who want to take advantage of the
open source big data space like a dupe
and spark we offer Google Cloud Data
proc and this allows you to run the
latest versions of Hadoop and spark in a
fully managed cluster in seconds I have
an arrow between these two things it
says full integration what does that
mean well full integration does means
that I don't have to draw little arrows
between each of these hexagons to tell
you this thing connects to that this
other thing connects this way you can
only do this with this other thing
full integration means all of these
products in Google cloud platform are
designed to work together seamlessly
without any extra effort on your part
but what about other things there are
other things that we do with data other
than load and store it and analyze and
understand it so let's take a bit of a
broader look we want you to be able to
ingest data into Google cloud platform
from anywhere and we do this in part
through technologies like our own google
cloud pub/sub which allows you to do
scalable message queue in from anywhere
in the world but also to tools that you
may use today like ETL tools such as
talent or data wrangling tools like
trifecta and on the other side we know
that it's important that you be able to
visualize data the way that you want to
explore it easily and share it with
others which is why both bigquery and
Google Cloud Data proc are fully
integrated with solutions like tableau
and MicroStrategy as well as with our
own solutions such as Google Analytics
360 and it's data studio 360 project and
with things like Google Cloud Data lab
which provides data scientists a
flexible environment to both write their
own code and integrate with systems like
bigquery now we talked earlier in this
webcast about the fact that bigquery is
fully managed what is fully managed mean
we think fully managed means getting
more it means that as a big query user
you get solutions like dynamic execution
immediately you wake up one day and
bigquery just got a lot faster your
queries got easier to write it also
means things like project Poseidon come
to you and you wake up and things get
better the Sidon allows you to all of a
sudden load new kinds of files such as a
bro file formats it also means that most
ingestions got 10 times faster you get
this all just one day without having to
do anything and then things like
consistent scheduling as we mentioned
big queries architecture allows us to
some of the vast number of CPUs
instantaneously to service your query
but at the same time we make sure you're
always going to have more than enough
resources to handle your queries it's a
fully managed means you get the latest
innovations without having to go through
painful upgrades whether it's on the
query execution side or the data storage
side it also means you always have the
resources you need to process your data
now I'm going to throw it back to chat
is going to talk a little bit more about
other partners and how they integrate
with Google
query
bigquery isn't trying to be everything
to everyone in places where we're not
building functionality we need to
partner with outstanding companies to
provide that functionality to our
customers you can see here four
different functional areas from
visualization to data preparation it's
important for bigquery to use these
other technologies so that you as a
company if you use MicroStrategy or if
you use talent or tableau you can still
use those tools but have bigquery as
your back-end thanks for taking the time
to watch the webinar on behalf of my
other speakers I just wanted to extend
that thank you and if you're curious
about learning more you can go to cloud
google.com / bigquery take care
[Music]